hola que tal bueno pues por aquí tenemos
la gráfica de y igual a 250 sobre 25 mas
x cuadrada y lo interesante aquí sería
ver cuál es el área bajo la curva de
toda esta parte de aquí incluso de las
colas con alcanzamos a ver a lo que me
refiero es que las partes con alcanzamos
a ver para cuando x tiende a menos
infinito por este lado y más infinito
por este otro lado entonces para ver el
área bajo dicha curva que es lo que
podríamos hacer como lo podríamos
denotar
bueno pues podemos denotar esta área con
una integral indefinida que iría de
menos infinito a más infinito de nuestra
función en nuestra función 250 sobre 25
más x cuadrada y todo esto de x
y bien nosotros hemos visto
anteriormente integrales impropias donde
uno de nuestros límites se va a infinito
pero bueno en este caso nuestros límites
van desde menos infinito hasta más
infinito y entonces qué es lo que pasa
aquí no podemos hacer límites de dos
cosas diferentes entonces lo que podemos
realizar en esta parte abordemos lo con
la integral impropia pero dividiéndolo
en dos partes donde la primera integral
impropia va a describir esta área que
estoy pintando de color azul y va a ir
de menos infinito a cero entonces irá de
menos infinito a cero con nuestra
función 250 sobre 25 más x cuadrada de x
más la segunda parte o nuestra segunda
integral impropia que la voy a pintar de
color magenta y va a ir de 0 a infinito
y una vez más ponemos nuestra función
250 sobre 25 demás x cuadrada de x y
ahora sí si lo vemos de esta forma todo
comienza a tener muchísimo más sentido
pero bueno lo que tenemos en la primer
parte de nuestra integral azul lo hemos
visto anteriormente y vaseline
cuando n tiene a tiende a menos infinito
de la integral de n a 0 de nuestra
función lo hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores por si tienes alguna duda
puedes regresar a ellos y después
tenemos más nuestra vamos a dar más
espacio nuestro límite para cuando ya
utilizamos n utilicemos ahora m para
cuando m tiende a infinito de 0 a hebe y
una vez más ponemos nuestra función 250
sobre 25 más x cuadrada de equis y ahora
lo que vamos a tener que hacer es
realizar dichas integrales y evaluarlas
en nuestros límites así que veamos cómo
nos va a ir quedando entonces tratemos
de imaginarnos cómo va a ir quedando la
integral la primera integral que tenemos
y lo pondré de este lado y no voy a
poner límite simplemente realicemos la
integral de una forma sencilla así que
tenemos la función de x y como veis por
acá abajo tenemos 25 más x cuadrada lo
cual
interpretarlo algo como cuadrada + x
cuadrada donde a sería igual a 5
entonces digamos que x es igual a 5
veces la tangente de teta y por qué digo
que x igual a 5 veces la tangente de
teta pues si te das cuenta tenemos una
fórmula especial que nos habla de que
cuando tenemos una constante arriba y
abajo la suma de dos números al cuadrado
pues podemos interpretarlo como la
integral de un arco tangente pero bien
empecemos por esto tranquilos y vamos a
despejar teta para que todos los
clientes de menos de teta y aquí tenemos
que teta es igual al arco tangente de x
sobre 5 y sale de despejar que x es
igual a 5 veces la tangente de teta y
ahora sí podemos regresar a nuestra
integral a nuestra función y ver cómo
nos va a quedar y bien ahora que tenemos
que x es igual a 5 veces la tangente de
teta veamos quién es de x px será igual
a 5 veces la secante cuadrada de teta de
teta entonces todo esto va a ser igual
ahora sí a la integral vamos a poner por
aquí la integral de 250
de x perdón de b x ahora es cinco veces
a secante cuadrada de theta por lo que
sería 250 x 5 secante cuadrado de teta
de teta y todo esto sobre todo esto
estará dividiendo a 25 más x cuadradas
pero x cuadrada ahora sería elevar este
término que pusimos por acá al cuadrado
que sería 25 tangente cuadrada de teta y
ahora simplemente tratemos de
simplificar todo esto lo cual nos va a
quedar de la siguiente forma sería 250 x
cinco veces la secante cuadrada de teta
sobre 25 por 1 más la tangente cuadrada
de teta de teta ahora bien el 25 se va
con nuestro 250 de arriba y simplemente
nos queda 10 que multiplica todo esto
pero antes recordemos que uno más la
tangente cuadrada de teta por
identidades trigonométricas es igual a
la secante cuadrada de teta sigue no
recuerdas muy bien esto será importante
que repasará todo tipo
entidad trigonométricas puesto que son
muy necesarias para este tipo de
integrales y bueno lo hice para
simplificar la cada vez más entonces se
nos va a cancelar la secante cuadrada de
arriba con la de abajo y simplemente nos
queda 10 por 5 de teta que esto se da
igual a 50 por la integral de teta ya
que el 50 porque ya no depende de theta
entonces simplemente nos va a quedar
este resultado como 50 veces teta más
una constante como lo hacemos siempre
para todo tipo de integrales y ahora sí
si regresamos a nuestro enunciado
original vemos que todo esto es respecto
de teta y en un inicio teníamos que para
nuestras principales integrales que
estábamos interesados todo era respecto
de x entonces ahora bien vamos a volver
a poner de la siguiente forma sería
igual a 50 veces el arco tangente de x
sobre 5 simplemente estoy cambiando
y bueno ahora vamos a los siguientes
regresemos a nuestra idea principal
teníamos que era el límite para cuando n
tiende a - infinito por este lado de
nuestra parte azul y simplemente
sustituimos nuestro resultado que ya
tenemos abajo que sea 50 arco tangente
de x sobre 5 evaluado de 0 a n dn a 0
perdona y luego teníamos más el límite
para cuando m tiende a más infinito y
volvemos a poner nuestro resultado del
límite que 50 arco tangente 50 arco
tangente de x sobre 5
y aquí evaluado aquí evaluado de 0 a m y
bien aquí me faltan un par de paréntesis
para que quede bien y ahora sí veamos
cómo va a quedar esto bueno pues ahora
si evaluamos no entonces tenemos que
esto va a ser el límite para cuando n
tiende a menos infinito de 50 veces arco
tangente de cero
sobre 5 - 50 veces el arco tangente de n
sobre 5 de m sobre 5 + todo esto más no
esta parte magenta que va a ser igual
vamos a hacer un poco más de espacio el
límite para cuando entiende además
infinito de 50 veces el arco tangente el
arco tangente de m sobre 5 menos 50
veces el arco tangente de 0 sobre 5 que
estaría aquí y bien para ayudarnos un
poco más con todo esto vamos a trazar un
círculo unitario para visualizar cómo se
evaluaría la tangente vamos a tener un
círculo unitario que tenemos por aquí y
es para visualizar nuestra función
tangente la tangente de una forma de
pensar en ella es con la pendiente sobre
la línea que determina el
que ayuda a definir el lado terminal de
los ángulos por ejemplo si tenemos un
ángulo que luce así este es un ángulo
que está sobre el eje de las x de su
lado positivo y esta línea de por aquí
entonces por lo que tenemos un ángulo de
esta forma y la tangente de dicho ángulo
será la pendiente de esta línea y una
forma de pensar esto es decir ok si
pensamos en el arco tangente de petah
decimos bien pues nos fijamos en esta
línea y determinamos donde la pendiente
es 0 y el ángulo donde dicho lado tiene
la pendiente 0 es el ángulo 0 entonces
esto se me van a cancelar y también de
este lado tenemos una interpretación
similar entonces ahora vamos a la
segunda parte vamos a fijarnos qué pasa
para cuando n tiende a menos infinito y
tenemos el menos 50 arco tangente de n
sobre 5 estamos diciendo que se tiende a
menos infinito entonces también vamos a
observar del otro lado cuando m tiende a
infinito de una expresión similar pero
aquí será de 50 arco tangente de m sobre
5 y bien pues entonces ahora vamos a
nuestro círculo unitario cuando n tiende
a infinito podemos verlo representado de
la siguiente forma que partimos de un
cierto valor que cada vez se va
aproximando más y más a menos infinito y
entonces si nos aproximamos más a este
valor hasta llegar a este punto de aquí
este ángulo de aquí es igual a menos pi
medios pues sí entonces tendríamos lo
siguiente el arco tangente para cuando n
tiende a menos infinito sería dicho
valor entonces sería simplemente
sustituir menos pi medios que acabamos
de obtener aquí en esta parte entonces
simplemente multiplicamos menos 50 por
menos y medios por menos y medios
entonces al hacer esta operación
simplemente nos va a quedar 25 25 pi y
bueno ahora vamos a la otra
interpretación qué pasa para cuándo
m tiende a infinito entonces dicha
pendiente se va acercando cada vez más
para acá va siendo cada vez más alta
hasta hacer casi vertical y llegar a
este punto de aquí entonces son
prácticamente simétricos pero esta parte
de por acá forma un ángulo de pi medios
un ángulo de pi medios y entonces
multiplicamos 50 por pi medios que nos
va a quedar también 25 pi por lo que el
aire que tenemos de color azul
regresando a nuestro problema original
esa parte esa área va a valer 25 pi y de
igual forma nuestra área anaranjada va a
ver el 25 y por lo que si ya calculamos
nuestra área bajo la curva nuestra área
total sería de 50 pib sería 25 más
25.050 pi y lo hemos hecho